Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. well-sealed windows no other country can make such well-sealed and nice windows this apparently was angela merkel's answer to a question asked by journalists more than a decade ago when the journalist asked her what she most associated with Germany. And that's the kind of detail that we expect in a column from the Restless History's top pundit, Dominic Sandbrick, who is here with me. And Dominic, you wrote this article, I think, just before the elections that were on Sunday. That's right.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。密封良好的窗户，没有其他国家能制造出如此密封且精美的窗户，这显然是十多年前安格拉·默克尔面对记者提问时的回答。当时记者问她对德国印象最深的是什么。这正是我们在《历史的余烬》顶级专栏作家多米尼克·桑布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）的文章中所期待的细节，他今天也来到了我身边。多米尼克，这篇文章我想是你刚好在周日大选前夕写的。没错。
That will be bringing the curtain down on Angela Merkel's 16 year reign as Chancellor of Germany. So we thought we'd do a kind of guerrilla look at not just Angela Merkel but the entire history of post-war German democracy. And this is obviously a subject that
这将为安格拉·默克尔长达16年的德国总理执政生涯拉下帷幕。所以我们觉得，不妨以一种“游击式”的视角来盘点一下，不仅是安格拉·默克尔，还有战后德国民主的整个历史。这显然是一个
particularly interests you. Well, I think like everybody in Britain, I was on the edge of my seat for the German federal elections. I know it's that's um it did seem to me that people in england were and britain were more interested uh in in this do you think so i don't think yes i think it's articles about merkel about wither germany all that kind of stuff well it may be in the broadsheets but i think it's a really interesting thing that people in Britain get so interested in American presidential elections. The BBC do. And, you know, these sort of incredibly consequential elections in the biggest, most powerful, most economically dynamic state in Europe kind of pass most people by.
你特别感兴趣的主题。嗯，我想像英国的每个人一样，我对德国联邦大选也一直悬着一颗心。我知道这……嗯，在我看来，英国人似乎对这个……你这么认为吗？我不认为——是的，我觉得有关于默克尔的文章、关于德国消亡的文章之类的内容。好吧，也许在严肃大报上是这样，但我发现一个非常有趣的现象：英国人对美国总统大选表现出极大的热情。BBC也是如此。而你知道，在欧洲最大、最强大、经济最具活力的国家发生这种具有极其深远影响的选举，却往往被大多数人忽视。
I mean, most people couldn't name the leaders of the CDU or the SPD, the two big German parties. Could you name them, Tom? I'm not, I don't actually think I could. Of course you could. I think it's, I think it's a really interesting and revealing thing. And actually German, German politics is much, I mean, it has this reputation in Britain of being just stupefyingly bland. Isn't that the point though? But I, well, I think this is the point, and this is historically really interesting. The point that you make in your article about Merkel
我的意思是，大多数人甚至说不出德国两大政党基民盟或社民党的领导人是谁。你能说出他们的名字吗，汤姆？我其实觉得我答不上来。你当然能。我觉得这是一个非常有趣且耐人寻味的现象。事实上，德国政治在英国人的印象中，往往被认为有着一种令人昏昏欲睡的平淡无奇。这不正是关键所在吗？不过，嗯，我觉得这正是关键所在，而这在历史上也非常有趣。你在关于默克尔的文章中指出
is that, in a sense, the kind of... the cosy tedium is precisely the point, because, of course, it's being set in contrast... Exactly. ..to what had happened up till 1945. Exactly. So when our producer said, you know, why don't you do something about Angela Merkel's departure and German politics?
从某种意义上说，那种舒适的乏味恰恰就是重点所在，因为这当然与……完全正确。……1945年之前发生的事情形成了鲜明的对比。完全正确。所以当我们的制作人说，你知道，为什么不做一个关于安格拉·默克尔卸任和德国政治的专题呢？
And I started looking in, thinking about the German post-war chancellors. I mean, they're all against the backdrop of the war. Indeed, both world wars in one way or another. I mean, they've all got the war in their personal history or in their family background. And actually, it turns out to be colossally more interesting than you think. And the blandness, the ordinariness, and the humdrum nature of German politics
我便开始着手研究，思考德国战后的历任总理。我的意思是，他们都以战争为背景。确切地说，都以这样或那样的方式经历过两次世界大战。我的意思是，他们的个人历史或家庭背景中都有战争的烙印。事实上，这比你想象的要有趣得多。德国政治的那种平淡、普通和乏味
is, as you absolutely say, it's part of the point. It's deliberate. And of course, Merkel has the communist period growing up in East Germany as well. So all the chancellors have, as this kind of backdrop, the experience of fascism and communism. Exactly. So I think what we should do, Tom, is rattle through the chancellors first. So to give people a sense of the context, because I think that's really important and interesting. And then probably in the second half or so, we'll see how we do. We can get on to Merkel. How does that sound? That sounds an excellent plan. Okay, so I'll kick off. So Germany in 1945, actually, just to think about the facts and
正如你所说，这正是重点的一部分。这是刻意为之的。当然，默克尔在东德长大，还有过共产主义时期的经历。因此，所有的总理都以法西斯主义和共产主义的经历作为这种背景。完全正确，汤姆。所以我觉得我们应该先快速梳理一下历任总理，好让听众对背景有个概念，因为我觉得这非常重要且有趣。然后大概在下半部分，我们看看进展如何，再来聊聊默克尔。听起来怎么样？这听起来是个绝佳的计划。好吧，那我就先开个头。1945年的德国，事实上，只需想想它的各项数据和
figures of it is astonishing. So there's 5 million people dead. There's 9 million men in allied, Western allied or Soviet prison camps. So Germany is, to an extent, that we in Britain, we sort of get very misty-eyed about Coventry Cathedral and the Blitz and all this sort of stuff. But this is a completely different order of magnitude of destruction,
数字，就令人震惊。有500万人在战争中丧生。有900万名军人身处盟军、西方盟军或苏联的战俘营中。因此，德国所遭受的破坏达到了这样一种程度：我们在英国，总是对考文垂大教堂和大轰炸之类的事情感到无限感慨，但这完全是另一个数量级的毁灭，
but also of kind of a moral destruction, this sort of moral humiliation. The country is on the verge of being divided. Yeah, it's about to be divided between um sort of allied and soviet zones uh in berlin 4 000 people are dying every day of disease in the second half of 1945 so it's i mean the germans call this stunde null so zero hour but they mean that in in that's got a kind of ambiguous meaning because on the one hand it means kind of they're absolutely the depths of degradation and despair
同时也是一种道德上的毁灭，一种道德上的屈辱。这个国家正处于分裂的边缘。是的，它即将被划分为……嗯，可以说是柏林境内的盟军和苏联占领区。在1945年的下半年，每天都有4000人死于疾病。所以我的意思是，德国人称之为“零时”（stunde null），但这个词带有一种含糊不清的意味。一方面，它意味着他们陷入了彻底堕落和绝望的深渊，
but at the same time they like to think of this and it's projected to them as a clean break with the Nazi past which is a bit of a well which is a complete myth actually because as we'll see there are tons of Nazis around I mean they don't all disappear
但与此同时，他们又愿意将此视为、并且这种观点也被灌输给他们：这与纳粹过去彻底决裂。但这其实是一个……嗯，实际上是一个彻头彻尾的神话，因为正如我们所见，周围到处都是纳粹分子，我的意思是他们并没有全都消失。
no and one of them becomes Chancellor becomes Chancellor exactly but Dominic have you read I mean, they don't all disappear. No, and one of them becomes chancellor. Becomes chancellor, exactly. But Dominic, have you read this new book that's just come out in English by Volker Ulrich, who wrote a great biography of Hitler, Days in May, How Germany's War Ended? So I haven't read this. Have you read this, Tom? I have. I actually just read it just before the idea for this podcast got suggested
是的，其中一人还成了总理。成了总理，完全正确。不过多米尼克，你读过……我的意思是，他们并没有全都消失。是的，其中一人还成了总理。成了总理，完全正确。不过多米尼克，你读过沃尔克·乌尔里希（Volker Ullrich）刚刚出版的英文新书吗？他曾写过希特勒的伟大传记《五日记：德国战争是如何结束的》（Days in May, How Germany's War Ended）？我还没读过。你读过吗，汤姆？我读过。其实我正是在有人建议做这个播客创意之前刚刚读完的，
which is why i was ready to say yes okay let's do it because um i mean it's full of it's brilliant it's kind of pointillist um depiction of the last eight days between the the suicide of hitler and um the the kind of complete surrender of germany so it's the kind of durnitz government isn't it yes so durnitz is is kind of supposedly in power but you have um all these kind of complete surrender of germany so it's the kind of durnitz government isn't it yes so durnitz is is kind of supposedly in power but you have um all these kind of little portraits of different people say people from the nazi regime um people who are its victims and um germans who were opposed to nazism so you get these portraits of various people who will become leading players in the history of the Federal Republic.
所以我当时才会准备说“好，我们来做吧”。因为……我的意思是，它充满了……它太精彩了，它就像点彩画一样……描绘了希特勒自杀到德国彻底投降这最后八天的细节。所以这讲的是邓尼茨政府，对吧？是的，所以邓尼茨可以说是在掌权，但是你有……所有这些……德国彻底投降的细节，所以这有点像邓尼茨政府，对吧？是的，所以邓尼茨可以说是在掌权，但是你会看到所有这些关于不同人物的小肖像，比如来自纳粹政权的人、作为受害者的那些人，以及反对纳粹主义的德国人。因此你会看到各种各样人物的画像，他们后来都成为了联邦共和国历史上的主要角色。
One of whom, of course, is Konrad Adenauer, who will become the first chancellor of the Federal Republic. But there's an amazing description of how he gets brought by the Americans to become mayor of Cologne. And he sees the cityscape of Cologne. And it's absolutely flat and the cathedral is you know devastated buildings are totally and he he can't he can't comprehend how the city could be rebuilt and the Americans say no we must you know you must rebuild it and so he he puts his shoulder to that particular wheel but the sense that even Adenauer who who plays such a crucial role in getting Germany back on its feet his first instinct is to say it can't be done well this is the extraordinary thing so there's
其中一人当然就是康拉德·阿登纳（Konrad Adenauer），他后来成为了联邦共和国的第一任总理。书中有段令人惊叹的描述，讲的是他如何被美国人带去担任科隆市长的。他看到了科隆的城市风貌，那里完全是一片平地，大教堂……你知道，建筑遭到毁灭性的破坏，他完全无法理解这座城市怎么可能重建。而美国人说，不，我们必须……你知道，你必须重建它。于是他把肩膀扛上了那根特殊的车轮（挑起了这个重担）。但给人的感觉是，甚至连阿登纳这样在让德国重新站立起来的过程中发挥了如此关键作用的人，他的第一直觉也是说这不可能做到。哦，这就是不同寻常的地方，所以还有
another another book that I read but called um came out this year also translates into English called Aftermath by a guy called Harold Yeener and he talks in that book it's basically how 10 the 10 years after the war so a lot of it is about denazification and the lack of and so on but he has a whole chapter about rubble um and basically there is so much rubble so many buildings have been destroyed that clearing it up is is the work of years and it's this colossal kind of national to begin with it's the women who have to do it right exactly because all the men are away because all the men are in so yeah i mean it's an absolutely mind-blowing story, which doesn't really get told in the West, because it's, you know, we won, the Germans lost,
另一本书我也读过，是今年出版的，也被翻译成了英文，书名叫《废墟之后》（Aftermath），作者是一个叫哈罗德·杰纳（Harold Yeener）的人。他在书中谈到了战后的头十年，所以很大一部分内容是关于去纳粹化以及缺乏去纳粹化等等。但他有一整章专门讲瓦砾……基本上，有太多的瓦砾，太多的建筑被摧毁，清理它们需要数年的工作，这是一项浩大的国家级……一开始，是女人们不得不去干这活，对吧？完全正确，因为所有的男人们都不在，因为所有的男人们都在……所以，我的意思是，这是一个绝对震撼人心的故事，在西方并没有真正被讲述，因为那是：我们赢了，德国人输了，
hurrah, hurrah, end of story. And in Germany, the way they told that story themselves was pretty distorted. So in his book, Aftermath, Jena says, basically, they repressed all memory of everything they'd done. Or we repressed, rather, he says. And he says, we coped by casting ourselves as victims. But having said that, I mean, there are heroes.
万岁，万岁，故事结束。而在德国，他们自己讲述这个故事的方式则相当扭曲。因此，杰纳在他的书《废墟之后》中说，基本上，他们压抑了对他们所做过的一切的所有记忆。或者说“我们压抑了”，他这样说道。他说，我们通过把自己伪装成受害者来应对过去。话虽如此，我的意思是，其中还是有英雄的。
And I think Adenauer does rank as a hero, doesn't he? So Adenauer is the, let's get into him. He's such a titanic figure. So when the Germans had a competition called Unsere Besten, they had a big vote where three million people voted. It was the equivalent of the Great Britain's contest that the BBC had at the beginning of the 21st century to find the greatest German in history. And Adonai won. Do you know who came second? You'd like this. Well, I'm guessing you didn't come second. Yeah, he was banned.
而且我认为阿登纳绝对算得上是一位英雄，对吧？所以阿登纳是……让我们来聊聊他。他是一个如此泰斗级的人物。所以当德国人举办了一场名为“我们最好的人”（Unsere Besten）的比赛时，有300万人参与了投票。这相当于BBC在21世纪初举办的“最伟大的英国人”评选，旨在寻找历史上最伟大的德国人。结果阿登纳赢了。你知道谁得了第二名吗？你肯定会喜欢的。好吧，我猜他没得第二名。对，他被禁了。
Goethe. No, come second. Yeah, he was banned. Goethe. No, Martin Luther. Oh, excellent. Karl Marx came third, interestingly. Anyway, Adenauer. So Adenauer is an extraordinary man. He is ridiculously old when he takes office. So he becomes Chancellor in 1949.
歌德。不，得第二名的是……对，他被禁了。歌德。不，马丁·路德。哦，太棒了。有趣的是，卡尔·马克思得了第三名。不管怎样，说回阿登纳。所以阿登纳是一个非凡的人。他上任时的年龄大得离谱。他是在1949年成为总理的。
This is when West Germany is finally up on its feet. He's 73 years old. He was born in 1876. And he'd been... You say about the Americans making a mayor of Cologne, he'd been deputy mayor of Cologne in 1909. I mean, imagine a man who'd been in politics in Britain. He'd been mayor of Cologne from 1917, hadn't he? Yes, he had.
当时西德刚刚重新站立起来。他已经73岁了。他出生于1876年。而且他曾……你刚才提到美国人让他当科隆市长，他早在1909年就已经是科隆的副市长了。想象一下这样一个在英国政坛待过的人。他从1917年起就已经是科隆市长了，对吧？是的，他确实是。
Up to the Nazis taking power. So you'll like him, no doubt, because his religion is very important to him. He's a Catholic. He's a Rhinelander. He's been part of the Centre Party. I mean, the great formational moment in Adenauer's political development was Bismarck's Kulturkampf against the Catholic Church. And he hates the Prussians as a result of this. Well, Dominic, would you, I mean, I know that I kind of bring this theme up every time, but would you not say that looking at the history of post-war Germany,
一直任职到纳粹夺取政权。毫无疑问你会喜欢他，因为他的宗教信仰对他的影响非常重大。他是一个天主教徒。他是莱茵兰人。他曾是中央党的一部分。我的意思是，阿登纳政治发展过程中最关键的形成时刻，是俾斯麦针对天主教教会的“文化斗争”（Kulturkampf）。因此，他由此对普鲁士人充满了厌恶。不过，多米尼克，你会……我的意思是，我知道我每次都会挑起这个话题，但你难道不认为，纵观战后德国的历史，
the Catholic and Protestant dimensions to it are actually incredibly, and even looking at the electoral map, as we're recording this on Monday, so the day after the election, and you have this kind of, the CDU, the conservative union founded, you know, Adenauer kind of led from the beginning.
其中的天主教和新教维度实际上是非常……甚至看看选举地图——在我们录制这期节目的周一，也就是大选后的第二天，你会发现有这样一种情况：基民盟，这个保守派联盟是由……你知道，阿登纳从一开始就领导的。
It's a very Catholic, kind of concentrated in the South, where historically Catholics have been concentrated. And the SPD to the North. Yes. Yeah, absolutely. Much more Protestant and Lutheran. And actually, when I went through this with doing the chancellors, I wrote down next to each one, Catholic or Protestant.
它是一个非常天主教化的政党，主要集中在南部，历史上天主教徒也一直集中在那里。而社民党则在北部。是的。没错。更加偏向新教和路德宗。事实上，当我通过梳理历任总理来研究这一点时，我在每个人的名字旁边都写上了“天主教”或“新教”。
And it's funny how it always points it out in there all biographies of them always mention it because it's so foundational in german politics that catholic so adnan hates prussians because he sees prussians as protestants anti-catholic all these kinds of things um it's why he's actually quite keen on the idea of setting up west germany he's actually not in some ways he's actually not that bothered about losing east germany because they're it's full of Prussians and he hates them. And he blames them for Nazism. So Adenauer presides over Germany till 1960. Well, but also, Dominic, just to say, I mean, just to say that his record under the Nazis, I mean, he sits it out, but he does get arrested, doesn't he?
有趣的是，他们的传记中总是会指出这一点，因为这在德国政治中是如此基础性的东西。所以阿登纳痛恨普鲁士人，因为他把普鲁士人视为新教徒、反天主教徒以及诸如此类的人。这也是为什么他对建立西德这个想法其实挺热心的。在某种程度上，他其实并不怎么介意失去东德，因为那里到处都是普鲁士人，而他恨普鲁士人。并且他将纳粹主义归咎于他们。因此，阿登纳一直主政德国直到1960年……不过，多米尼克，顺便说一句，我的意思是，就他在纳粹统治下的记录而言，他虽然采取了冷眼旁观的态度，但他确实被捕过，不是吗？
Twice. He's in prison twice. Yeah. After the knife, the long knives, and then again in the war. And he tries to escape, gets arrested again, taken to the Gestapo cell, somehow managed to get out. So, I mean, you know, he's... He's got a great record. It's not surprising that the Germans voted him as their best German,
两次。他被关押过两次。一次是在长刀之夜后，另一次是在战争期间。他试图逃跑，结果再次被逮捕，被关进盖世太保的牢房，但不知怎么设法逃了出去。所以，我的意思是，他……他的履历非常漂亮。难怪德国人投票选他为最伟大的德国人，
because, you know, it's a great story. So he's a very old man. One thing he does do is he scraps denazification. So he says, basically, we can't go on having endless trials and interrogations and so on. We need to get the country back up on its feet and we need to shut this down. And effectively, he shuts it down pretty soon
因为，你知道，这是一个了不起的故事。他当时已经是一个非常老的老人。他做的一件事就是废除了去纳粹化。因此他基本上说：我们不能再进行无休止的审讯和盘查了。我们需要让这个国家重新站立起来，我们需要把这件事情收尾。实际上，在他出任总理后不久，
after taking over as chancellor. And he prioritises recovery and rebuilding rather than kind of, you know, accounting for all the sins. He says we can't account for all the sins of the past. Now, authors like Harold Yeaner say this is sort of poor stuff. But I suppose you could make an argument that, from a point of view of pure pragmatism, because so many people were implicated in the Nazi regime
他就相当迅速地终止了去纳粹化。他把经济恢复和重建放在首位，而不是去清算所有的罪孽。他说我们无法清算过去的所有罪孽。现在，像哈罗德·杰纳这样的作家认为这很不地道。但我想你可以提出这样一个论点：从纯粹实用主义的角度来看，由于有那么多人都卷入了纳粹政权，
to get Germany on its feet, especially given the pressure of the Cold War, he probably had to shut it down to some extent. But of course, he then becomes some, goes on to become a sort of founding father of European unification and so on. The alliance with France. The alliance with France.
为了让德国重新站立起来，特别是考虑到冷战的压力，他可能不得不某种程度上叫停去纳粹化。但当然，他随后成为了欧洲统一等事业的奠基人之一。与法国结盟。与法国结盟。
Yeah, he takes Germany to NATO. He re-arms West Germany. So, and he's 87 when he retires. So he makes Joe Biden look like him. Yeah. And he remains head of the CDU until he's 87 when he retires so he makes Joe Biden look like yeah and he remains head of the CDU until he's 90 yeah ridiculous I mean because because the the guy who succeeds him Ludwig Erhardt yeah never actually although he leads a CDU government never actually joins the CDU no he's a very a political figure actually ludwig erhardt i just wanted last thing on a ad now an amazing fact i found um in 1957 in the ministry of justice in 1957 this is
是的，他带领德国加入北约。他让西德重新武装。而且他退休时已经87岁了。所以他让乔·拜登看起来像他……是的。而且他一直担任基民盟领袖直到87岁退休，所以他让乔·拜登看起来像……是的。而且他担任基民盟领袖直到90岁，是的，这太荒谬了。我的意思是，因为接替他的那个家伙——路德维希·艾哈德（Ludwig Erhardt）——虽然领导了基民盟政府，但实际上从未加入过基民盟。不，路德维希·艾哈德实际上是一个非常非政治化的人物。我只想补充关于阿登纳的最后一件趣事，我发现……1957年，在1957年的司法部里，这
sort of volkswagen rebuilding germany you know germany's a cuddly again and the economic miracle is underway in 1957 eight out of ten officials in the Ministry of Justice had been Nazis. So that's the sort of dark side, if you like, of the Adenauer regime. Now, Ludwig Erhardt, we're talking about the World Wars. Here's a great sort of World War story. He's Bavarian, so a Catholic part of Germany, but he has a Protestant mother. And he's raised as a Protestant. Who raises him as a Protestant.
有点像……大众汽车在重建德国，你知道，德国又变得讨人喜欢了，经济奇迹正在进行中。1957年，司法部里十分之八的官员都曾是纳粹分子。所以，如果你愿意的话，这就是阿登纳政权黑暗的一面。现在，说到路德维希·艾哈德，我们刚才在谈论世界大战。这里有一个很棒的第一次世界大战故事。他是巴伐利亚人，也就是德国的天主教地区，但他有一个新教母亲。他是作为新教徒抚养长大的。是谁把他抚养长大的？
Exactly right. And he fights in World War I on both fronts. And he's badly injured at the Fifth Battle of Ypres. Gary Sheffield would enjoy these facts. As my grandfather was. Really? But your grandfather didn't become economics minister in a post-war German government. No.
完全正确。他在第一次世界大战中在两线作战。他在第五次伊普尔战役中受了重伤。加里·谢菲尔德（Gary Sheffield）会喜欢这些事实的。就像我祖父一样。真的吗？但你祖父没有成为战后德国政府的经济部长。没有。
A notable man, no doubt, in his own right but um yeah uh and did your grandfather have his one arm shorter than the other i don't think so ludwig erhardt he looked excellent in the hat did he your grandfather or ludwig erhardt uh my grandfather because i don't know whether i don't know whether i have i've seen pictures of erhardt in a hat actually did he lookon Johnson. Yeah, he looked very good. He was kind of grinning, brown-faced. He was kind of a roly-poly guy. Yeah, very roly-poly. So he's not really one of life's politicians. So during the 1930s, the Nazi era,
毫无疑问，他也是个杰出的人物，但是……嗯……呃，你祖父的两只胳膊有没有一只长一只短？我想没有吧。路德维希·艾哈德……他戴帽子看起来很帅，对吧？你祖父还是路德维希·艾哈德？呃，我祖父。因为我不知道……我不知道我是否……我其实看过艾哈德戴帽子的照片。他看起来很……林登·约翰逊。是的，他看起来很棒。他总是咧着嘴笑，晒得棕黑。他是个圆滚滚的人。是的，非常圆滚滚。所以他并不是那种生来就是政客的人。所以在20世纪30年代，即纳粹时期，
he'd actually worked as an economist for the German finished goods industry, for the Association of Finished Goods Manufacturers. So there was boring stuff happening before the federal republic yeah he sort of kept his head down and uh he's he's a technocrat mid-60s he falls after three years because he's seen as too pro-american i think by and large and he's just not very political and and so he falls and now we have a nazi yeah so now we have this very very interesting character so imagine i mean if you were so for a brief shining moment he's the world's most famous
他实际上曾为德国成品工业担任经济学家，为成品制造商协会工作。所以在联邦共和国之前，发生过很多无聊的事情。是的，他基本上保持低调，呃，他是一个技术官僚。在60年代中期，他上台三年后就下台了，因为大体上他被认为过于亲美，而且他实在不太懂政治，所以他下台了。然后我们迎来了一个纳粹分子。
kissing or kiesinger as he's called kurt georg kiesinger but then of course he's completely eclipsed by henry kissinger something like you were spider-man tom yeah it is you know so so yeah so a certain degree of fellow feeling yeah well you're but you're not a nazi and never have been no that's true so so tell us about his record as a nazi well first of all he comes from and how he ends up as as chancellor he's um he's from baden wurttemberg in the southwest now he's the reverse of ludwig ehart so he comes from a family of protestants but his mother was a catholic and she brought him up as a catholic and it's interesting is it not this how many of them have a bit of both bit of catholic and a bit of protest very
是的，现在我们有了一个非常非常有趣的人物。想象一下，如果当时你是……所以在一段短暂而耀眼的时期里，他是世界上最著名的库尔特·格奥尔格·基辛格（Kurt Georg Kiesinger），或者简称基辛格——但当然，他后来完全被亨利·基辛格给黯然失色了。就像你扮演蜘蛛侠一样，汤姆。确实是这样……所以，是的，在某种程度上算得上是同命相连吧。好吧，但你不是纳粹，也从来都不是。是的，这倒没错。所以，给我们讲讲他作为纳粹的履历，
interesting and also the mother being the the sort of outsider who pushes them into her confession and that sort of slight sense of outsideness i wonder if that plays a part so good this is me my freudian psychology anyway but plugging into church history in an excellent way. Good to see you. I finally got you. So Kurt Georg Kiesinger, I mean, he's a careerist. So he joins the Nazi party in 1933. There's only one reason you join the Nazi party in 1933.
很有意思，还有母亲作为那种局外人，把他们推向她的忏悔，那种微微的局外感，我想知道这是否也起到了作用——太棒了，这是我的弗洛伊德心理学——不过它以一种绝妙的方式切入了教会历史。很高兴见到你。我终于找到你了。库尔特·格奥尔格·基辛格，我的意思是，他是个投机政客。所以他在1933年加入了纳粹党。1933年你加入纳粹党只有一个原因。
It's that they're in power. You know, because if you're, you know, that's why he's done it, obviously. And he has this, we can say, colourful history, working with Ribbentrop and Goebbels, producing propaganda, anti-Semitic propaganda. Because he doesn't fight, does he? No, he's a pen pusher. He's a pen pusher who basically kind of ends up making propaganda for the Foreign Office. So that's basically what he does. And he just does this consistently.
那就是他们掌权了。你知道，因为如果你……显然他就是为了这个才这么做的。他有着我们可以称之为丰富多彩的历史，曾与里宾特洛普和戈培尔共事，制作宣传片，反犹宣传片。因为他没有参战，对吧？没有，他是个文牍主义者。他是个文牍主义者，最后基本上沦为替外交部制作宣传片。所以这基本上就是他所做的事。而且他一直都在这样做。
Even after he knows that that what's happening to the jews so after it's kind of common knowledge um he carries on doing it so there's basically no you know he's he's a kind of at best you would say he's a he's an amoral careerist at the worst you say he's just an utter nazi and and what's interesting about so he is chance of what 66 to 69 so this is the and has 1968 in the middle slap bang in the middle of that term of office when um anxieties among teenagers people in the early 20s students about nazis so this is your genesis of the Baader-Meinhof group. This is your, you know, he's very critical of,
甚至在他知道犹太人的遭遇之后——也就是在事情广为人知之后——嗯，他还是继续这样做，所以基本上没有……你知道，他是个……往好了说，你会说他是个毫无道德底线的投机政客；往坏了说，你会说他是个彻头彻尾的纳粹。有趣的是，他是66到69年的总理，所以正值1968年，正好卡在他任期的正中央。当时青少年、20岁出头的年轻人以及学生对纳粹的焦虑情绪……所以这就是巴德-迈因霍夫集团的萌芽。这就是你的……你知道的，他非常严厉地批评……
you know what he said about the baby boom generation? A shameful crowd of long-haired dropouts who need a bath and someone to discipline them. So, you know, he's not holding back. He's leaning into his reactionary reputation. So the CDU conference, he gets slapped, doesn't he? Yes, he does. By a protester.
你知道他是怎么评价婴儿潮一代的吗？“一群留着长发的无业游民，厚颜无耻，需要洗个澡，还需要有人管教。”所以，你知道的，他毫不掩饰。他倾向于维持他那反动派的名声。所以在基民盟（CDU）大会上，他挨了一巴掌，对吧？是的，确实如此。被一个抗议者。
So I'm not surprised. A Nazi hunter. A Nazi hunter, yes. She's Beata Carsfield, and she slaps him in the face at the CDU convention while shouting at him, Kiesinger, you're a Nazi, step down. So, I mean, it's all out there. mean it's not good optics is it no um and yet this is what's fascinating and actually this takes me back to that book aftermath about the after you know the about the aftermath the
所以我一点也不惊讶。一个纳粹猎人。一个纳粹猎人，是的。她叫贝塔·卡尔斯菲尔德，在基民盟代表大会上，她当众扇了他一巴掌，同时冲他喊道：“基辛格，你是个纳粹，下台吧！”所以，我的意思是，这全在明面上。我的意思是，这形象可不太好，对吧？没有，嗯……然而这正是最迷人的地方，实际上这让我想起了那本关于余波的书——关于二战……
second world war um a lot of germans you know you don't often hear this now and actually it's not part of almost the received narrative of sort of german post-war history but a lot of germans actually don't feel very apologetic about the second world war or indeed about nazism opinion polls show that very clearly lots of people think you know oh here's the problem is he went too far and kiesinger wins almost 50 of the vote in 1969 is is that more presumably more true of people on the right than the left? Or am I being unfair? No, I'm sure that's true. To the EU voters there.
二战后的余波，嗯……很多德国人，你知道，你现在不常听到这种说法，而且这实际上几乎不属于战后德国历史主流叙事的一部分，但许多德国人实际上对第二次世界大战并没有什么歉意，对纳粹主义也没有。民意调查非常清楚地显示了这一点：很多人认为，哦，问题在于他走得太远了。基辛格在1969年赢得了近50%的选票。这在右翼选民中是不是比左翼更普遍？还是说我不够公正？不，我相信这是真的。那里的欧盟选民。
I'm sure that's true. Because for the SPD, the left. Yes. I mean, that is different, isn't it? And so the guy who succeeds Kissinger, Willy Brandt. Great character. Yeah. He's a fabulous character. Yes, he is.
我相信这是真的。因为对于社民党（SPD）来说，也就是左翼。是的。我的意思是，那是不一样的，对吧？所以接替基辛格的人是维利·勃兰特。伟大的性格。是的。他是个极了不起的人物。是的，他确实是。
Absolutely. I mean, you know, his whole life is anti-fascist. Yes, anti-fascist. So, of course, he's not billy brant no that's not his name it's an alias imagine if we had a british prime minister who governed in the 70s under imagine if ted heath was an alias or james callahan so actually his real name is herbert fram um and he's the son of a single parent department store cashier who never he never knows his father in lubeck the whole lubeck yes incredibly beautiful city i've never been to lubeck i have i've got a friend who lives in lubeck oh very nice uh when you visit will you
绝对的。我的意思是，你知道，他的一生都在反法西斯。是的，反法西斯。所以，当然，他不是比利·勃兰特——不，那不是他的名字，是个化名。想象一下，如果我们有一位英国首相在70年代执政，用的是……想象一下如果泰德·希思是个化名，或者詹姆斯·卡拉汉。所以其实他的真名叫赫伯特·弗拉姆，嗯，他是一个百货商店收银员的单亲家庭的孩子，他从来不知道自己的父亲是谁，在吕贝克。整个吕贝克，是的，极其美丽的城市。我从未去过吕贝克。我去过，我有个朋友住在吕贝克。哦，太棒了，嗯，当你去的时候，你会……
bring me back oh you must buy marzipan and i definitely like marzipan but i like marzipan a lot to be polite i bought quite a lot when you next go please bring me back some lubeck marzipan but i like marzipan a lot to be polite i bought quite a lot when you next go please bring me back some louis beck marzipan anyway we're going off piste um yes so willie brandt uh he's a socialist he's you know card carrying absolute sort of quite hard left um in the standards of the 20s uh he flees germany uh when the nazis come in he has to. He goes to Norway and Greece and Spain. And Willy Brandt is one of his many aliases. And when he comes back to Germany at the end of World War II, he decides it's a better name than Herbert Fram.
给我带回……哦，你一定要买杏仁糖，我确实喜欢杏仁糖，但我非常喜欢杏仁糖。为了礼貌，我买了不少。你下次去的时候，请务必给我带点吕贝克杏仁糖。但我非常喜欢杏仁糖，为了礼貌，我买了不少。你下次去的时候，请务必给我带点吕贝克杏仁糖。不管怎样，我们扯远了。嗯，是的，所以维利·勃兰特，他是个社会主义者，是个持有党证、绝对算得上是20年代标准的相当激进的左翼。当纳粹上台时，他逃离了德国，他不得不这么做。他去了挪威、希腊和西班牙。维利·勃兰特只是他的众多化名之一。当他在二战结束时回到德国时，他觉得这个名字比赫伯特·弗拉姆更好听。
And he ends up being mayor of West Berlin. And I think he's right, isn't he? Because, I mean, it's a great name. Yeah, it is a good name. And he's built up hugely by Kennedy. So Kennedy identifies him quite early on and says, this guy's a tremendous fellow. You know, we should sort of build him up. And Kennedy, obviously, when he goes to make his speech in West Berlin, Ich bin ein Berliner, Willy Brandt is at his side.
他最后成了西柏林的市长。我觉得他是对的，对吧？因为，我的意思是，这是个好名字。是的，确实是个好名字。肯尼迪非常器重他。所以肯尼迪很早就注意到了他，并说：“这家伙是个了不起的人才。你知道，我们应该好好扶持他。”肯尼迪显然在西柏林发表那次演讲时——“我是柏林人”（Ich bin ein Berliner）——维利·勃兰特就站在他身旁。
And the Americans are very keen on Willy Brandt. But Willy Brandt is kind of, he's the voice of youth. He's the voice of, he says, you know, we need more reform. We need more democracy in Germany. And he comes in in 1969 as part of a coalition, I think, after, so Kiesinger is out and he comes in. I mean, he's less, he's kind of become more centrist, doesn't he? Since his early firebrand socialist days.
美国人非常喜欢维利·勃兰特。但维利·勃兰特某种程度上是……他是青年之声。他是……的声音，他说，你知道，我们需要更多的改革。我们需要德国有更多的民主。他在1969年作为一个联盟的一部分上台，我想，在……所以基辛格下台了，他上台了。我的意思是，他没那么……他变得更温和了，对吧？自从他早年激进的社会主义者时期以来。
Yes, absolutely. And so he does, I mean, he's very pro-American. I mean, whether that's because... Well, you have to be pro-American in West Germany because America is defending you against... I mean, isn't he backing Vietnam and things like that? Yeah, and that's one of the things that West German government... And he hates communists.
是的，绝对的。所以他……我的意思是，他非常亲美。我的意思是，不管是因为……好吧，在西德你必须亲美，因为美国在保护你免受……我的意思是，他不是在支持越南战争之类的事情吗？是的，那是西德政府的一大……而且他痛恨共产党人。
Yeah, of course. He's a Keir Starmer figure. That really... Cracking down on the left. Keir Starmer has never been on the run. No. I don't see him as a man leading a... I withdraw that analogy. But he is also...
是的，当然。他是个基尔·斯塔默式的人物。这真……严厉打击左翼。基尔·斯塔默可从来没被通缉过。不。我不认为他是一个领导……我收回这个比喻。但他也……
I mean, the famous thing he does is Ostpolitik. Ostpolitik, so basically recognising East Germany. Exactly. Which none of the previous chancellors have done. No, they basically said East Germany is illegitimate. He he says let's normalize relations then we can both join the un the other thing he does the one thing that he's very famous for in the in sort of um outside germany and i found this fascinating when i discovered this so this extraordinary moment in 1970 when he goes to warsaw to the the memorial to the um ghetto uprising in warsaw yeah and he kneels in this
我的意思是，他做的最著名的事情就是“东方政策”（Ostpolitik）。东方政策，也就是基本上承认东德。没错。这是以前的所有总理都没有做过的。没有，他们基本上说东德是不合法的。他……他说让我们实现关系正常化，然后我们都可以加入联合国。他做的另一件事——他在德国以外的地方非常著名的一件事，当我发现这件事时，我感到非常震惊——那是1970年发生的一件非同寻常的事：他去了华沙，来到华沙犹太区起义纪念碑前，是的，他在这个……
fantastic photograph incredibly you know it's a very moving moment and and it's always taken i think in sort of anglo-american textbooks and things you know this is a sign of the new german in all this what is absolutely fascinating is that a plurality of germans did not agree with him so 48 of west germans thought not agree with him so 48 percent of west germans thought that was wrong to have knelt why why did they think it was wrong well you can can you not i mean they thought it was yeah it's unpatriotic unpatriotic too much um groveling you know you don't have to it's it's uh it's too dramatic it's too you know we shouldn't be doing that we should be
神奇的照片中下跪了。令人难以置信的，你知道，这是一个非常感人的时刻。在英美教科书之类的地方，它总是被解读为……你知道的，这是新德国的象征。然而绝对令人着迷的是，相当一部分德国人并不同意他的做法。48%的西德人不赞同他的做法——48%的西德人认为下跪是错误的。为什么？为什么他们觉得那是错的？好吧，难道你不能……我的意思是，他们认为那是……是的，是不爱国的。不爱国，太卑躬屈膝了，你知道，你没必要这么做，这太……这太戏剧化了，太……你知道的，我们不应该那样做，我们应该……
forgetting you know a whole load of reasons which you can complete if a british prime minister did it for something at amritsar yeah right you can imagine the commentary so it's kind of not dissimilar i think um yeah i mean not to downplay the amritsar massacre but it's it's not quite on the scale of the holocaust no of course not of course not i mean i mean but that's what's so interesting that in 1970 even as lots of young germans the sort of barda meinhof type people and their fellow travelers are saying this place is full of nazis we haven't got over the you know we've we've buried our guilt we haven't admitted it and all this even at that moment 48 of their fellow citizens are saying branch should not have knelt um at the at the ghetto memorial so he's very popular anyway
忘掉它，你知道，有一大堆理由，如果你能想象一下，如果一个英国首相为阿利萨（Amritsar）事件做类似的事情，是的，对吧，你可以想象当时的评论。所以这其实也差不了多少，我想……嗯，我的意思是，并不是要轻描淡写阿姆利萨惨案，但它跟大屠杀的规模还是不太一样。不，当然不是，当然不是。我的意思是，但这就是最有趣的地方：在1970年，甚至当许多年轻的德国人——比如巴德-迈因霍夫式的人物和他们的同路人——在说“这个地方到处都是纳粹，我们还没有从过去走出来”、“我们掩盖了自己的内疚，我们没有承认它”等等时，就在那个时刻，他们48%的同胞却在说，勃兰特不应该在犹太区纪念碑前下跪。所以无论如何他非常受欢迎……
with sort of liberal minded intellectually kind of people so artists and and all this um gunter grass exactly but he has this um he's a to use your brother's terminology he is a massive lad so i think it's our terminology as well there's a there's a lot going on with the ladies and there's a lot of drink being taken and he also suffers from depression so and also he has a secretary doesn't he who has an unfortunate turns out to have an unfortunate background uh gunter guillaume I think his name is. So he's basically a German spy. Have you seen the brilliant Michael Frayn play about that?
在具有自由主义思想、知识分子类型的人群中——比如艺术家和诸如此类的人，冈特·格拉斯正是如此。但他有一个……用你兄弟的话说，他是一个地道的“花花公子”（lad）。我想这也是我们的常用语。他和女性之间发生了很多故事，而且他经常酗酒，他还患有抑郁症。而且他还有一个秘书，对吧？那个人的背景后来被证明不太妙。冈特·吉尧姆（Günter Guillaume），我想他叫这个名字。所以他基本上是个德国间谍。你看过迈克尔·雷恩（Michael Frayn）关于那件事的精彩戏剧吗？
No, I haven't. Democracy. Yeah. It's really good. I think it was on at the National, it must have been 20 years ago or something like that. And it had Roger Allum, who is in... Was he Willy Brandt? Of course, in Endeavour now.
没有，我没看过。民主（Democracy）。是的。真的很好。我想它当时在国家剧院上演，那大概是20岁前或者什么时候的事。里面有罗杰·阿拉姆（Roger Allum），他在……他演的是维利·勃兰特吗？当然，现在在《摩斯探长前传》（Endeavour）里。
Yeah. Yeah, he was Willy Brandt. Yeah, he'd be very good as... Yeah, he was fabulous. Really fantastic. It still lives vividly in my memory. So ever since, Willy Brandt has been my favourite Chancellor. But Willy Brandt doesn't resign
对。是的，他演的是维利·勃兰特。是的，他演得非常……是的，他演得棒极了。真的太棒了。它依然生动地活在我的记忆中。所以从那以后，维利·勃兰特一直是我最喜欢的总理。但维利·勃兰特辞职……
just because of the spy. The spy is kind of the trigger. You know, he's sick of it anyway. Okay, so I may have got that wrong then. You know, there's a memorial to him. You love these walks. There's a memorial to Willy Brandt in Hammersmith. Is there?
不仅仅是因为那个间谍。间谍只是一个导火索。你知道的，他反正也受够了。好吧，那我可能弄错了。你知道，那里有一座为他建的纪念碑。你太喜欢这些漫步了。在哈默史密斯（Hammersmith）有一座纪念维利·勃兰特的纪念碑。是吗？
He donated, when he was Mayor of West Berlin, a memorial to him. You love these walks. There's a memorial to Willy Brandt in Hammersmith. Is there? He donated, when he was mayor of West Berlin, a lamp or lantern and swapped it with Hammersmith. They twinned with some part of West Berlin. And it's still there with a little plaque underneath saying Willy Brandt. I'll go and search that out. I don't think it's worthy of a podcast before you get excited. No, but possibly
他在担任西柏林市长时，捐赠了一座纪念碑。你太喜欢这些漫步了。在哈默史密斯有一座纪念维利·勃兰特的纪念碑。是吗？他在担任西柏林市长时，捐赠了一盏灯或路灯，并与哈默史密斯进行了交换。他们与西柏林的某个地方结成了友好城市。它现在还在那儿，下面有一个小铭牌，上面写着“维利·勃兰特”。我要去找找看。在你兴奋之前，我觉得它还不足以成为一个播客的话题。不，但可能……
worthy of a little stroll. Very good. Do we have time for one more before the break do you think well i think we i think we should we should whistle through because i think that the the later ones will be kind of escalatingly more familiar we're about to get into my favorite one though helmut schmidt helmut schmidt he was a nazi as well well i think you're being hard so he literally he literally joined the wehrmacht in wait a second wait a second so he was in the Hitler Youth.
值得稍微散个步。非常好。你觉得在休息前我们还有时间再讲一个吗？嗯，我想我们……我想我们应该快点讲完，因为我觉得后边的那些会越来越熟悉。不过我们马上就要讲到我最喜欢的那一个了，那就是——赫尔穆特·施密特。赫尔穆特·施密特。他也是个纳粹。嗯，我觉得你对太苛刻了。所以他简直……他简直是在……等等，等等，他在希特勒青年团。
He was kicked out of the Hitler Youth for not being a Nazi, for being anti-Nazi. For being arrogant, I thought. But then it's very ambiguous, because he's then back in the Hitler Youth, and there are reports from his superiors saying, he's a great Nazi. Yeah.
他因为不是纳粹、因为反纳粹而被开除出希特勒青年团。我以为是因为他太傲慢了。但随后这变得非常含糊，因为他后来又回到了希特勒青年团，并且有来自他上级的报告说：“他是个很棒的纳粹。”是的。
So he's a teenager. He's dithering. He doesn't know what he is. We've all been there he's wrestling with his with his ideological convictions but yes he fights
所以他那时是个青少年。他在犹豫不决。他不知道自己是什么。我们都经历过那个阶段。他在与自己的意识形态信念作斗争，但是是的，他参战了。
he has an amazing war he fights on the eastern front he fights he's at the siege of Leningrad and on the drive on Moscow yes he's at the trial I think the evidence is stacking up here
他经历了一场惊人的战争。他在东线作战，他参加了列宁格勒围城战，也参加了进攻莫斯科的战役。是的，他在审判……我想证据在这里越来越确凿了。
but he's a German he's in the German army yes and he's about 12 I don't know he's signed up to the German army he's attacking Moscow he's laying siege to Leningrad he's in the german army i mean and he's about 12 i don't know i mean he's signed up to the german army he's attacking moscow he's laying siege to leningrad he's at the trial of the staufenberg conspirators but not on trial he's just watching uh and then he fights at the back that i gather is what changed his is that right i didn't know that i didn't know that he goes there
但他是个德国人，他在德军里。是的，他当时大概12岁……我不知道，他加入了德国军队，他在进攻莫斯科，他在围攻列宁格勒，他在德军里——我的意思是，他当时大概12岁，我不知道——我的意思是，他加入了德国军队，他在进攻莫斯科，他在围攻列宁格勒，他在施陶芬贝格密谋分子的审判现场，但不是受审，他只是在旁观。然后他参加了后方的战斗，我收集到的资料显示，正是那件事改变了他的……是这样吗？我不知道这一点。我不知道他去了那里。
and i think this this is from from Ulrich's book. Yeah. That he attends this hearing of the conspirators against Hitler. And it's only then that he realizes that the Nazis are criminal. And he says this himself, apparently, in an interview that he did later in life. Too late, Schmidt added. He'd realized it's too late. Yeah, so I think he was
我想这出自乌尔里希（Ulrich）的书。是的。他出席了这场针对希特勒的密谋分子的听证会。正是在那之后，他才意识到纳粹是罪犯。据报道，他在晚年的一次采访中自己也这么说过。“太晚了，”施密特补充道。他意识到时已经太晚了。是的，所以我觉得他……
he was compromised and then he kind of he realised it he admits his compromise though Tom I like that about him he admits his compromise I knew he was
他曾与纳粹妥协，然后他意识到了这一点。不过他承认了自己的妥协，汤姆，我挺喜欢他这一点。他承认了自己的妥协。我早就知道他……
yes he absolutely admits it he goes on to fight he still fights he fights in the Battle of the Bulge he fights in the Ardenne but he's I think
是的，他绝对承认了这一点。他继续战斗，他还在战斗，他参加了突出部战役（Battle of the Bulge），他参加了阿登战役，但我认为……
he's on a journey by that point he's on his journey right he's on a journey he's captured by the British, isn't he? Yeah, well, he ends up becoming a Social Democrat. He does indeed.
那时候他正在经历一个转变。他正在经历转变，对吧？他正在经历转变。他被英国人俘虏了，对吧？是的，嗯，他最后成了一个社会民主党人。他的确如此。
So he takes over from Willy Brandt. He's very pro-European. He's very hard on the Baader-Meinhof group. He takes an incredibly hard line against them in the so-called, what's it called, the German... I can't remember what it's called. It's either called the German Spring, the German Summer, or the German Autumn. I can't remember which one of them. I'm sure it's not the German Winter.
所以他接替了维利·勃兰特。他非常亲欧。他对巴德-迈因霍夫集团非常严厉。他对他们采取了极其强硬的立场，在所谓的……叫什么来着，德国……我记不清叫什么了。要么叫“德国之春”，要么叫“德国之夏”，要么叫“德国之冬”。我记不清具体是哪个了。我敢肯定不是“德国之冬”。
Springtime for Germany. Anyway, it's one of these things where they're at their peak and they've kidnapped Hans Martin Schleyer, or whatever his name is, the head of the German business group, and it's all very big news. Anyway, he's a chain smoker. He's great pals with... Callaghan.
德国之春。不管怎样，这是他们正处于鼎盛时期的一件事，他们绑架了汉斯-马丁·施莱尔（Hans Martin Schleyer）或诸如此类的人——德国企业联合会的负责人，这当时是个轰动一时的大新闻。不管怎样，他是个老烟枪。他和……卡拉汉是好哥们。
Callaghan, Gerald Ford. They go on holiday together when they've fallen from office. I'd love to write a play about this. That's very Michael Frayn. He could play with that. Henry Kissinger said he hoped he... What did he say he hoped? He died before Helmut Schmidt
卡拉汉，杰拉尔德·福特。他们卸任后还一起去度假。我很想写一部关于这个的戏剧。那非常符合迈克尔·雷恩的风格。他可以就此发挥。亨利·基辛格说他希望他……他说他希望什么？他希望自己死在赫尔穆特·施密特前面。
because he wouldn't like to live in a world that didn't have Helmut Schmidt in it. Obviously a man of incredible charm. Which is a very nice thing. Charm and charisma. When Margaret Thatcher became Britain's Prime Minister, Helmut Schmidt went around saying to all the other leaders, this is going to be awful, she's the most dreadful bitch.
因为他可不想生活在一个没有赫尔穆特·施密特的世界里。显然是一个极具魅力的人。这真的是一件非常美好的事情。魅力与个人感召力。当玛格丽特·撒切尔成为英国首相时，赫尔穆特·施密特到处对其他领导人说，这太糟糕了，她是个最可怕的泼妇。
Oh. But then he pitched up in London and they got on really well. Because she kind of had a bit of a fancy for kind of chain-smoking cats. Yeah, he was kind of Cecil Parkinson-type looks, didn't he? And when he used to come to meet you know they used to meet up she used to say to him i love talking to you because you're the only world leader ever me who's more right wing than i am um because he although he's in the spd he's very kind of hard line on something because he'd become very hard line economically so um yeah i like i am a great fan of helmut schmidt i think he's a
哦。但后来他到了伦敦，他们相处得非常好。因为她有点喜欢那种老烟枪型的政客。对，他长得有点像塞西尔·帕金森那种类型，不是吗？当他来见她时——你知道，他们过去常常会面——她曾对他说：“我喜欢和你交谈，因为你是我遇到的唯一一个比我还右翼的世界领导人。”嗯，因为他虽然身属社民党，但在某些方面却非常强硬，因为他在经济上变得非常强硬，所以……嗯，是的，我是赫尔穆特·施密特的超级粉丝，我认为他是一个
great character he's obviously obviously very, very charismatic, perhaps in a way that quite a lot of German chancellors deliberately haven't been. Like Ted Heath, he was very big on the piano. He recorded piano music. He was arrested in later life for smoking against the smoking ban. Massive lad.
了不起的人物。他显然非常、非常有个人魅力，这种魅力或许是很多德国总理刻意没有的。就像特德·希特一样，他非常热衷于钢琴。他录制过钢琴音乐。晚年时，他因为违反禁烟令吸烟而被捕。绝对是个狠角色。
Yeah, massive lad, exactly. He contributed an article to a festschrift for the philosopher Karl Popper. I mean... He's the complete Chancellor. He's the German... I mean, maybe apart from the war. He's the German Chancellor you'd want to be, isn't he?
对，绝对是个狠角色，没错。他曾为哲学家卡尔·波普尔的纪念文集撰写过文章。我的意思是……他是最完美的德国总理。他就是德国……我的意思是，或许除了战争那段历史。他就是你希望成为的那种德国总理，不是吗？
Yes. Yeah, he is. Now, maybe at this moment we should take a break. We haven't got to Angela Merkel yet, but maybe that's the story. But we have the huge bulk of Hel coal looming looming towards us so let's take a quick break and then when we get back um more germans more germans don't go away germans we got them i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews reviews, splash of showbiz gossip.
是的。没错，他正是如此。现在，也许在这个时候我们该休息一下了。我们还没聊到安格拉·默克尔，但或许这才是故事的关键。不过，科尔那庞大的身躯正向我们逼近，所以我们先快速休息一下，等我们回来后……会有更多的德国人，更多的德国人，不要走开，德国人，我们这就讲。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐而已》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你们每周获取娱乐新闻、精彩评论和八卦猛料的固定节目。
And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Today I read on Twitter from a satisfied listener to our James Bond podcast that what was great about The Rest Is History's Bond podcast was that it wasn't full of the flippancy and clichés that you get from so many
在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及提前购买现场活动门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史而已》（The Rest Is History）。今天我在推特上看到一位满意听众对我们的詹姆斯·邦德播客的评价，他说《历史而已》的邦德播客之所以棒，是因为它没有充斥着你在许多播客中听到的那种轻浮和陈词滥调……
podcasts whether people will say that about this podcast about post-war german politics remains to be seen but as tom said we now confront yeah the vast bulk of helmut kohl so helmut kohl is probably the german chancellor who gives german chancellors not exactly a bad name i mean he's a colossus isn't he's a political in every sense but he is quite boring but it's again i mean we've said this throughout that the boringness is a quality. Yeah. And if you're not boring, then there's a faint hint of suspicion, I guess, as happens with Schmitt.
人们是否会对这档关于战后德国正如汤姆所说，我们现在面对的是……没错，庞大的赫尔穆特·科尔。所以，赫尔穆特·科尔大概是那位给德国总理们带来……也不能算坏名声……我的意思是，他是一个巨人，不是吗？他在任何意义上都是一个政治巨人，但他也相当无趣。不过话说回来，我们之前一直说过，无趣也是一种品质。是的。如果你不够无趣，就会让人产生一丝怀疑，就像对施密特那样。
Schmitt famously said, there was talk about German politics lacking vision. And Schmitt said, you know, if you're seeing visions, you need to consult a doctor. And I think, yes, and some listeners to the podcast will say, oh, this giggling about politicians being boring is typical of a british flippancy and a and a and a sort of deliberate nihilistic silliness which is you know sort of landed british has resulted in boris right and that actually you
施密特曾有一句名言，当时有人谈论德国政治缺乏远见。施密特说：“如果你看到了远见，那你需要去看医生。”我想，是的，播客的一些听众会说：“哦，这种嘲笑政客无趣的态度，正是英国人轻浮的表现，是一种蓄意的、虚无主义的愚蠢，这种态度……你知道的，英国式的轻浮导致了鲍里斯的出现。”而实际上，你知道……
know you why are you laughing at helmut kohl being boring when actually helmut kohl is an is a incredibly serious and important figure well, you know the father of modern Germany? Do you know who called him that? Margaret Thatcher. Right. Well, Margaret Thatcher, of course, and Helmut Kronen have this terrible relationship. But she admired him.
为什么你要嘲笑赫尔穆特·科尔无趣，而实际上赫尔穆特·科尔是一个极其严肃且重要的人物？好吧，你知道现代德国之父是谁吗？你知道谁这么称呼他吗？玛格丽特·撒切尔。没错。好吧，玛格丽特·撒切尔和赫尔穆特·科尔之间的关系当然非常糟糕。但她很钦佩他。
They're both on the centre-right, so she can't forgive him for German reunification. You know what she says about German reunification? We defeated the Germans twice, and now they're back, which is obviously not very constructive. Well, Mitterrand basically felt the same, didn't he? The president of France. Yeah, but he didn't say it publicly.
他们都属于中右翼，所以她无法原谅他促成了德国统一。你知道她对德国统一是怎么说的吗？“我们打败了德国人两次，现在他们又回来了。”这显然不是什么建设性的言论。密特朗基本上也是这么想的，对吧？法国总统。对，但他没有公开说出来。
No, he didn't say it publicly, but he was kind of, you know, phoning up Mrs. Thatcher and they were moaning away about the Germans. But Mitterrand didn't come out. I can't remember whether we talked, I think we did talk about this, but I enjoy it, so I'll talk about it again on our anglo-german relations podcast so she went over to visit helmut kohl in germany and and this is they're obviously both
不，他没有公开说。但他会……你知道的，给撒切尔夫人打电话，两人一起抱怨德国人。但密特朗并没有公开表态。我不记得我们有没有聊过这个，我想我们大概聊过，但我觉得很有意思，所以我就在我们的英德关系播客里再聊一次。所以她去德国访问了赫尔穆特·科尔，而这两人显然都是……
center-right leaders they're both you know invested in the cold war they're both friends he's cdu he's catholic he's from the rhine yes i mean they should get on fine and actually he's determined that they will get on fine. And he takes her to the platanet, the Rhineland platanet, where he's from. And he takes her to his hometown of Ogersheim. I mean, well, I think all German politicians should come from somewhere called Ogersheim. He takes her to his favourite restaurants, and they have a lot of sausages and stuff. And then he takes her to the cathedral in Speer, in the platanet,
中右翼领导人，他们都……你知道的，都经历过冷战，他们都是朋友。他是基民盟的，他是天主教徒，他来自莱茵兰。是的，我的意思是他们本来应该相处得很好，而且事实上他也下定决心要和她搞好关系。他带她去了莱茵兰的普法尔茨，那是他的家乡。他带她去了他的家乡奥格斯海姆。我的意思是，好吧，我觉得所有德国政客都应该来自一个叫奥格斯海姆的地方。他带她去他最喜欢的餐厅，他们吃了大量的香肠之类的东西。然后他带她去了普法尔茨施派尔的大教堂，
where eight Holy Roman emperors are buried I've been there have you is it a good cathedral oh it's fantastic yeah I mean if you if you love 10th and 11th century German history there's nowhere better which I do yeah no I've got 20 children there and he takes he take did you god what you should have gone with Margaret Thatcher so Helmut K, or with Helmut Kohl. So he takes her in, and while they're behind a pillar or something, he says to Charles Pohl, her foreign policy guy, he says, this is really important for me, this.
那里埋葬着八位神圣罗马帝国皇帝。我去过那里。你去过？那是个好大教堂吗？哦，太棒了！如果你热爱10世纪和11世纪的德国历史，没有比这更好的地方了。我确实很热爱。不，我在那里有20个孩子……他带她去……天哪，你应该和玛格丽特·撒切尔一起去，或者和赫尔穆特·科尔一起去。所以他带她进去，当他们站在一根柱子后面时，他对她的外交政策顾问查尔斯·鲍尔说：“这对我来说非常重要，真的。”
This is the quote. It's absolutely crucial that Mrs Thatcher knows I consider myself a European first and a German second. And he takes her in, he shows her the tombs and all that, and then she leaves. And the first thing she says is, god that man is so german and of course he is very german yeah um and he's not he wouldn't work in britain but he works in germany precisely because of the lack of color lack of vision all of those kinds of things but to mrs satchett's credit i think you know the father of modern germany she wouldn't just say that.
原话是这样的：“撒切尔夫人知道我把自己首先看作一个欧洲人，其次才是一个德国人，这至关重要。”他带她进去，给她看陵墓等等，然后她就离开了。她说的第一句话是：“天哪，那个人太德国了。”当然，他的确非常德国，对吧？嗯，他如果在英国是行不通的，但在德国行得通，恰恰是因为他缺乏色彩、缺乏远见以及诸如此类的特质。但平心而论，我认为对于撒切尔夫人所说的“现代德国之父”，她绝不仅仅是随口说说。
No, no. She didn't come out with guff. And clearly she could recognise, despite the fact that she didn't like him in the way that she'd obviously liked Schmidt, that he was a titanic figure. Yeah. Which he really was. Which he was. Because he is the Chancellor who presides over the reunification of Germany. And they do it so quickly, within a year.
不，不。她没有说废话。很显然，尽管她并不像喜欢施密特那样喜欢他，但她能看出他是一个划时代的人物。没错，他确实是。他确实是。因为他正是 presiding over（主持）德国统一的总理。而且他们行动如此迅速，在一年之内就完成了。
So quickly and effectively and efficiently. Yeah. I mean, it's very costly at the time. Costy for everybody. It's costly for East Germans because they are disadvantaged. You know, they're economically disadvantaged and so on. But, you know, in the long run, it obviously worked and turned Germany into the powerhouse that it now is.
如此迅速、有效且高效。是的。我的意思是，当时代价非常高昂。对所有人来说都很昂贵。对东德人来说也很昂贵，因为他们处于不利地位。你知道的，他们在经济上处于劣势等等。但是，从长远来看，它显然发挥了作用，把德国变成了如今的经济大国。
There's an argument that had he delayed and delayed, you know, people would have started to find objections and so on, but he really went for it. For a very kind of stolid-looking man, it was an act of almost swashbuckling kind of decisiveness. And, yeah, absolutely played... He had a very sad ending, Helmut Kohl. So he had... I don't know if it was a stroke or something like that,
有一种观点认为，如果他一拖再拖，你知道的，人们就会开始挑出各种反对意见等等，但他真的当机立断。对于一个外表看起来非常呆板的人来说，这几乎是一种意气风发、果断绝伦的举动。而且，绝对发挥了……赫尔穆特·科尔的结局非常悲惨。他经历过……我不知道是中风还是别的什么，
but basically, while he was in hospital um he ended up marrying somebody who was about 40 years younger than himself who then kept him well this is contested but basically his family claimed that she kept him as a virtual prisoner and he fell out with the whole of the rest of his family very sad story so that was the end of him anyway he was replaced by a a man who i think shyster yeah am i allowed to say that absolute so gerhard schroeder really shouldn't be a german politician i mean he's a british politician yes he's a sort of tory mp from the major government something yes he is he's made a fortune kind of flogging second-hand cars so so his father was killed in world war ii when he was a baby in Romania.
但基本上，当他在医院的时候……他最终娶了一个比自己小大约40岁的女人，后来这个女人把他的生活……好吧，这一点存在争议，但基本上他的家人声称这个女人把他软禁了，而且他跟其余所有的家人都闹翻了，这是一个非常悲惨的故事。总之，这就是他的结局。后来他被一个……我认为是个骗子的人取代了。对，我能这么说吗？绝对的。所以格哈德·施罗德其实根本不应该当德国政客，我的意思是，他应该是个英国政客。是的，他有点像是梅杰政府里那种托利党下议院议员，对吧？是的，他靠倒卖二手车发了财。所以……他的父亲在二战期间他在罗马尼亚还是个婴儿时就阵亡了。
He's a Lutheran. Well, nominally I think he's actually an atheist. Grew up in Westphalia. I'm supposed in 1982... Are you reading this off from Wikipedia? No, I'm reading it off my notes. I'm reading it off my notes. 1982, he supposedly visited the federal
他是路德宗信徒。嗯，名义上我想他其实是个无神论者。在威斯特法伦长大。我猜在1982年……你这是在照着维基百科念吗？不，我是从我的笔记上念的。我是从我的笔记上念的。1982年，他据称喝醉了酒来到联邦
chancellery, drunk, and shouted, I want to get and shouted i want to get in i want to get in and eventually he did in 1988 amazing story amazing um but because he was quite i mean he was quite he's bad left he was quite hard left oh yes yeah and then he gets into power and he basically chums up with tony yeah you should love him he's third way he's pure third way so blair clinton and schroeder kind of very very uh his his economic policies are really quite right wing yeah but i think actually the truth of the matter is politically he's been completely eclipsed by his behavior so he's been married five times you know what the germans call him the lord of the
总理府，大喊：“我要进去，我要进去！”最后他在1988年真的进去了。真是个惊人的故事，太惊人了……嗯，因为他相当……我的意思是，他相当……他是极左派，他曾是极左翼。哦，对，对。然后他掌权了，基本上和托尼·布莱尔混在了一起……对，你应该喜欢他，他是“第三条道路”的忠实信徒，纯正的“第三条道路”。所以布莱尔、克林顿和施罗德这几个人……非常非常……他的经济政策实际上相当右翼。是的，但我认为事实的真相是，在政治上，他完全被自己的私生活给黯然失色了：他结过五次婚。你知道德国人怎么称呼他吗？“戒指之王”。
rings so previously germans have no sense of humor previously they called him when he was married four times they called his nickname was audi man and then now they call him olympic man i mean it's a he's a parody his wives have become progressively younger um but the other thing is the is the russia's hair i mean yeah it's shocking paul mcgarney's sort of level um the other shocking thing about gerhard schrader is the russia stuff so which is which is a story that will run with merkel as well yeah he became a lobbyist for gazprom and rosneft and all these russian companies you know he spent his 70th birthday party in the yusupov palace in st
在此之前，德国人……德国人其实没什么幽默感……此前他结过四次婚时，他们的绰号叫他“奥迪男”（因为有四个圈），而现在他们叫他“奥运男”。我的意思是，这简直是个笑话，他的妻子们越来越年轻。不过除此之外，还有……还有俄罗斯的事情。我的意思是，这太令人震惊了，简直达到了保罗·麦卡特尼那种级别……关于格哈德·施罗德，另一件令人震惊的事就是他跟俄罗斯的那些勾当，这也是后来默克尔时代延续下来的故事。是的，他成了俄罗斯天然气工业股份公司（Gazprom）、俄罗斯石油公司（Rosneft）以及所有这些俄罗斯公司的游说者。你知道的，他在圣彼得堡尤苏波夫宫度过了他的70岁生日派对，座上宾就是弗拉基米尔·普京。
petersburg and the guest of honour was Vladimir Putin. And there's no doubt, I mean, he's been paid for a lot of this. You know, he's just become, as you say, a complete and utter shill, basically, for the Putin regime. And he's kind of huge behind the Nord Stream, bringing the Russian gas directly to Germany and bypassing Ukraine. So I think we're going to come to that, because this is obviously one of Angela Merkel's great legacies, is the Nord Stream gas pipeline.
毫无疑问，我的意思是，他为此拿了很多钱。正如你所说，他基本上已经彻底沦为了普京政权的走狗。而且他在“北溪”项目背后发挥了巨大作用，将俄罗斯天然气直接输送到德国，同时绕过了乌克兰。所以我想我们接下来会谈到这一点，因为这显然是安格拉·默克尔的伟大政治遗产之一，也就是“北溪”天然气管道项目。
So now we've come to Angela. And, of course, this will be music to your ears because her religious background is very important. Which is why she opens the last chapter in Dominion. I've forgotten that. I'm not blanking out Dominion. I mean, it's like Calais, it's engraved on my heart. So each chapter begins with a scene,
现在我们来聊聊安格拉了。当然，这一定会让你大饱耳福，因为她的宗教背景非常重要。这也是为什么她是《多米尼恩》（Dominion）最后一章的开篇人物。我都忘了。我可没有把《多米尼恩》忘在脑后。我的意思是，这就像加来一样，深深地刻在我的心头。所以每一章都以一个场景开场，
21 chapters spanning 2,500 years. And the last one is Angela Merkel on TV in Rostock with a Palestinian girl who's a refugee, who's come to Rostock for medical treatment and now has to go back. And she asks Merkel, why do I have to go back? I don't want to go back. And Merkel says, well, basically that's tough.
21个章节跨越了2500年。最后一章是安格拉·默克尔在罗斯托克的一档电视节目中，面对一个巴勒斯坦难民女孩。这个女孩为了治疗来到罗斯托克，现在不得不返回。她问默克尔：“为什么我非得回去？我不想回去。”默克尔说：“嗯，基本上这就是现实。”
It's the way things are. We can't have everyone over here. And the girl bursts into tears and Merkel looks embarrassed. And then a few weeks later, in the face of the great migrant crisis, refugees from Syria and Afghanistan and so on crossing Europe, she unexpectedly opens the borders. And my thesis, which is not original to me because i think lots of people think it is that this is very powerfully influenced by the the parable
事情就是这样。我们不可能把所有人都接到这里来。女孩放声大哭，默克尔显得很尴尬。然后几周后，面对巨大的难民危机——来自叙利亚和阿富汗等地的难民穿过欧洲——她出人意料地打开了边境。我的论点——这并非我的原创，因为我认为很多人也这么认为——是这深受“好撒玛利亚人”比喻的影响，
of good samaritan which she would have absolutely absorbed at the feet of her father who was a lutheran pastor who very unlike most people at the end of the war, are going from East Germany to West Germany. He goes from Hamburg to Berlin to keep the Lutheran fire alive in what's obviously going to become communist East Germany. But it's not just the Lutheranism, though, is it? Isn't it also her sense of what we've been talking about in in this podcast of german history and of german guilt and german's obligations germany's obligations to the world absolutely but i also wonder i mean with her so her father i mean when he goes there
她绝对是在她父亲身边耳濡目染长大的。她父亲是一位路德宗牧师，在战争结束时，他与大多数人截然不同，没有从东德逃往西德，而是从汉堡前往柏林，要在那个显然将成为共产主义东德的地方让路德宗的火种延续下去。但不仅仅是因为路德宗，对吧？难道这不也体现了我们在本播客中一直讨论的德国历史意识、德国的罪责感以及德国对世界的义务吗？绝对是的。但我也在想，关于她……她父亲……当他去那里时……
i mean there's this kind of lutheran idea that you know of church and state that you don't really worry about what the state is you focus on the church which kind of enables him morally to to live and work in east german society but i i mean obviously merkle has i mean she is she is still a kind of devout lutheran and it obviously does inform her her morality and her politics and her seriousness i think yeah um but when that when the berlin war comes down and um east germany becomes part of west germany and you know fused into the federal republic she joins the cdu the conservatives and a cat you know catholics and she's a lutheran but i think that that, you know, so her father was called Red Casner. So her father was, you know, that was her maiden name.
有一种路德宗的观念，即关于教会与国家的关系——你不用太去操心国家是什么样，你只需专注教会。这从道德上使他能够在东德社会中生活和工作。但我认为，显然默克尔有……我的意思是，她仍然是一个虔诚的路德宗信徒，这显然影响了她的道德观、政治观以及她的严肃态度，我认为是这样的。但是当柏林墙倒塌，东德并入西德，融入联邦共和国后，她加入了基民盟——这个保守党派，里面有天主教徒，而她是路德宗信徒。但我认为，她的父亲被称为“红色卡斯纳”。所以她父亲……那是她的婚前姓。
I wonder whether, as well as a kind of Christian commitment, she also inherited from that experience a kind of mistrust of wild idealism of the kind that her father had shown by going to East germany i don't know her mother her mother was deeply opposed to the move east so they went against the mother's wishes and obviously the fact that he was called i find that fascinating that he was called red
我在想，除了某种基督教的坚定信念之外，她是否也从那段经历中继承了一种对狂热理想主义的不信任——就像她父亲当年去东德时所表现出的那种理想主义？我不知道。她母亲……她母亲极其反对这次搬迁，所以他们是违背了母亲的意愿去的。而且他被称为“红色卡斯纳”，我发现这太迷人了，因为我认为他之所以被称为这个，是因为他显然带有中左翼的同情倾向。
casner because i think he's called that because he clearly has left of center sympathies definitely and that's what enables her to get the great education that she does. Yeah. Because what's interesting about her as well is that, and actually this does tie in with some previous chances, you know, to Helmut Schmidt and the people who are in the Hitler Youth and so on. She is in, you know, the, she works as a,
毫无疑问，正是这一点让她获得了极其优异的教育。是的。关于她，还有一个有趣的地方，这其实也与之前的几位总理相呼应，比如赫尔穆特·施密特以及那些曾加入过希特勒青年团的人。她曾在……
I mean, there's a lot of argument about this in Germany about exactly what she did, but she probably worked as a propaganda officer for the sort of the main, you know, state-sponsored communist youth organisation in the GDR. She was never anything vaguely, remotely resembling a dissident. And she's completely, you know, she's been completely open about that. She sort of said it would be career suicide,
她曾作为……德国关于她具体做过什么有过很多争论，但她可能曾担任过民主德国（GDR）主流官方支持的共产主义青年组织的宣传干官。她从来没有哪怕一点点类似异见人士的迹象。对此她一直完全坦诚。她曾说过，那将是职业上的自杀，
it would be, you know, very damaging for my family. This is this is obviously true of you know millions upon millions of people in east germany she kept her head down and um you know sort of got on with it and well she's not a radical no and it's always safety first yeah and there's the famous story isn't that when the berlin war comes down that she goes and has a look and then she goes back because she's got to get up and she's got work the next morning. Exactly. Absolutely. Exactly right. And I think, you know, she won big student Russian competition.
那会对我的家庭造成极大的伤害。这对于东德千千万万的人来说显然是事实。她谨小慎微，把头埋低，安分守己地过日子。她不是一个激进分子，不，而且她总是把安全放在第一位。有个著名的故事，不是吗？当柏林墙倒塌时，她去看了看，然后就回去了，因为她第二天一早还得起床上班。完全正确。绝对如此。完全正确。而且我认为，她赢得了全国俄语大赛的冠军。
She worked, you know, she had a head down for years, for years. You know, we're talking about 10 years or more um in science you know you know what our thesis is our research paper tom do you know the title of a research paper i don't it's vibrational properties of surface hydroxyls non-empirical model calculations including anharmonicities well what does that tell you nothing i don't know what any of that means well i guess what it might tell you is that i mean she she has a lutheran background yeah she obviously has a background in hard science yes uh science operates and you know who this is this is leading us towards who she's very similar to yes yes uh in in so many ways and yet in so many ways not to mr satcher i guess yeah to margaret
她工作……多年来一直谨小慎微，多年来……我们说的是十年或更长时间……在科学领域。你知道我们的论文是什么吗？我们的研究报告，汤姆，你知道我们的研究报告的标题是什么吗？我不知道。是《表面羟基的振动性质：包含非谐性的非经验模型计算》。这能说明什么？什么也说明不了，我根本不知道这些都是什么意思。好吧，我想它可能说明的是……她有着路德宗的背景，
thatcher i think it's both scientists both from you know what we would call non-conformist or low church backgrounds and both consistently underestimated by their male opponents until the moment when they reveal themselves more opportunistic more cunning you know what helmut helmut kohl she stabbed ended up stabbing him in the back at the end of the he appoints her fairly quickly he Minister for Women in the CDB. Just like Ted Heath and Margaret Thatcher, actually. She comes on board as a token woman. She's a pure...
她显然拥有硬科学的背景，科学是如何运作的……你知道这在引导我们走向她和谁非常相似吗？是的，在很多方面都是如此，但在很多方面又不像……我想是像玛格丽特·撒切尔吧？对，玛格丽特·撒切尔。我认为这两位都是科学家，都出身于我们所说的新教非主流派或低教会背景，并且两人的男性对手都一致低估了她们，直到她们展现出自己更具机会主义、更精明的一面——你知道吗？赫尔穆特·科尔最终在任期结束时被她从背后捅了一刀。他很快任命她为基民盟的妇女部部长。
And Cole patronises her dreadfully. He goes around, he says, this is my midget and this is my girl kind of thing. You know, this is my little mascot from the East who I'm showing off. And he introduces... I think he introduces someone like george bush senior in this incredibly condescending way i mean this is a woman who's been a research scientist for 10 years in the east um and then you know quietly all the time people call her the snake
就像特德·希特任命玛格丽特·撒切尔一样。她作为象征性的女性加入内阁。她纯粹是一个……而且科尔极其居高临下地对待她。他到处说：“这是我的小矮人，”或者“这是我的小丫头”之类的话。你知道的，“这是我从东部带过来炫耀的小吉祥物。”他把……我想他以一种极其居高临下的方式把她介绍给老布什等人。我的意思是，这可是一位在东方做过10年研究科学家的女性……然后，在那些年里，人们悄悄地称她为“蛇”。
in the in the in the 90s but the con the contrast with mrs that is that Mrs Thatcher kind of made a virtue out of, you know, the smoke and crash of battle. Yeah. I mean, she would advance towards fire. Yes. Whereas Merkel, it seems, has always done the opposite. Yes, she has. And this is the criticism that you read in a lot of the commentary. Well, it's not necessarily criticism, is it?
但在90年代，她与撒切尔夫人的对比在于，撒切尔夫人将政治斗争的硝烟与碰撞变成了一种美德。是的。我的意思是，她会迎着战火向前冲。是的。而默克尔似乎总是反其道而行之。是的，确实如此。这也是你在许多评论中读到的批评。不过，这也不一定是批评，对吧？
Well, no, because it's brilliant short-term politics, right? But is it not also going with the grain of what Germans want? It probably is. Because, again, if you compare it to Britain, one of the things about British politics that is Merkel's criticism of it is that it's flippant it's short term it it yeah unnecessarily sensationalist and aggressive sensationalist kind of you know rolling things on a throw of the dice all that kind of stuff which which you might say reflects the fact that um britain didn't undergo a fascist dictatorship wasn wasn't kind of defeated in two world wars wasn't divided
嗯，不，因为这是出色的短期政治手腕，对吧？但这难道不也顺应了德国人的心理需求吗？可能确实如此。因为，再次与英国相比，英国政治的一个特点——也是默克尔对英国政治的批评——在于它太轻浮、太短期、不必要地煽动性且富有攻击性，
didn't have a quarter of the country under communist dictatorship so Britain is able to kind of treat recent history in a faintly flippant manner, in a way that Germans can't and shouldn't that she has
喜欢通过掷骰子来碰运气，诸如此类。你可以说，这反映了这样一个事实：英国没有经历过法西斯独裁，没有在两次世界大战中被击败，没有被分裂，四分之一的国土没有处于共产主义独裁之下。所以英国能够以一种隐隐有些轻浮的态度来对待近代史，而德国人既不能也不会这样做。
how would you not have that sense if you'd grown up in East Germany in a way that German Germans can't. That's absolutely right. Yeah, absolutely right. That she has. How would you not have that sense if you'd grown up in East Germany? And if you grew up growing up with that, the experience of the two world wars, the Holocaust and so on, Nazism hanging over you as all Germans have to this day. The interesting question, I suppose,
如果你在东德长大，你怎么可能没有那种感受？而德国人则不然。这绝对是对的。是的，绝对如此。她有这种感受。如果你在东德长大，经历过两次世界大战、犹太人大屠杀等历史，以及至今仍悬在所有德国头顶的纳粹主义阴影，你怎么可能没有这种感受？我想，有趣的问题是，
is when that runs out, you know, when will German politics become flippant? And well, I did. I mean, so if you think of uh of johnson with his kind of ironic post-modern yet also faintly serious identification with churchill yeah but it's all a bit of a joke it's a kind of oxford union debating pose yeah
当这一切耗尽时——你知道，德国政治什么时候会变得轻浮？嗯，我是说……如果你想想约翰逊，他那种具有讽刺意味的后现代主义，同时又隐隐带着对丘吉尔的严肃认同感……是的，但这一切都有点像是个笑话，带有某种牛津辩论社的姿态。
and you contrast that with the the palpable influence that the experience of growing up under a communist dictatorship has had on merkel you know the the difference in seriousness is obviously immense i mean who is to say perhaps extreme seriousness can be overdone because i do think i did i do you know obviously the, obviously the Johnsonian approach is all about let's create chaos. Let's throw the dice. Let's see what happens. And, you know, as the queues at petrol stations grow, we can see what some of the consequences of that might be. But equally, I suppose one of the criticism of Merkelism would be that she's incredibly reactive.
如果你把这与在共产主义独裁下长大的经历对默克尔造成的显而易见的影响进行对比，那种严肃程度的差异显然是巨大的。谁又能说极端的严肃就不会过头呢？因为我确实认为……约翰逊的方法全在于制造混乱。让我们掷骰子，看看会发生什么。正如加油站前排起的长队所显示的那样，我们可以看到其中一些后果会是什么样。但同样地，我认为对默克尔主义的批评之一在于她极其被动。
Yeah. Is that fair? I mean, i think it probably is fair she's not a very crisis to blow up and then she kind of responds to them exactly and she often responds to them in ways that aren't necessarily great well the example a good classic example of the eurozone so you know if you're listening to the podcast from portugal ireland greece or spain your take on angela mer Merkel might be very different from, you know, somebody's take in Germany, you would say, she punished us, she made us clients of, you know, German manufacturing, made it impossible for us ever to be competitive,
是的。这公平吗？我的意思是，我认为这大概是公平的。她不是一个喜欢主动出击的人。危机爆发了，然后她才做出回应。而且她做出的回应往往并不一定是绝佳的。一个很好的经典例子就是欧元区。所以，如果你在葡萄牙、爱尔兰、希腊或西班牙收听这个播客，你对安格拉·默克尔的看法可能会与德国人的看法非常不同。你会说：“她惩罚了我们，她把我们变成了德国制造业的附庸，让我们永远无法拥有竞争力，”
because the austerity put in place with that came with the bailouts at the beginning of the 2010s. So yeah, I mean, I think there's a sort of fantasy the which is which is which by the way is brilliant politics that you know i'm a pure pragmatic scientist but i'm also an idealist right making the right decisions but kind decisions in the national interest um and that is that is yeah the muti kind of exactly i'm the nanny you've got to go to bed early because it's for your own good because you've got school and it's slightly different it's interesting that sort of that that female archetype i mean i think i think one of the great stories of politics actually in the last 30 40 years is what a terrible time women politicians have well she hates she hates the
因为2010年代初伴随救助计划而实施的紧缩政策。所以，是的，我认为存在一种幻想……顺便说一句，这是高超的政治手腕……即“我是一个纯粹务实的科学家，但我也是一个理想主义者，做出正确的决策，但同时也是为了国家利益做出仁慈的决策”。这就是那个“妈妈”形象的由来……没错，“我是保姆，你得早点上床睡觉，因为这为你好，因为你还要上学”。虽然略有不同，但这种女性原型很有意思。事实上，我认为过去30到40年政治界最精彩的故事之一，就是女性政客的境遇是多么糟糕。
nickname doesn't she and she does and how subject we are to stereotypes i mean margaret thatcher was was always seen as the nurse who gives you the really harsh medicine. I mean, she sort of embraced that herself. Or the doctor who prescribes, you know, you need to have both legs amputated to save your life. Merkel is exactly the mother who tucks you up at night with kind of soothing words. You know, she gives you...
嗯，她讨厌那个绰号，不是吗？她的确讨厌。而且我们是多么容易受到刻板印象的影响。玛格丽特·撒切尔总是被视为那个给你开猛药的护士。我的意思是，她自己也某种程度上接受了这一点。或者说是一个医生，开出的处方是“为了保命，你必须截掉双腿”。而默克尔恰恰是那个用安慰的话语哄你入睡的母亲。她给你……
The mother who serves you porridge, basically. She's not giving you something really horrible not giving you something terribly nice either but she that sort of mother of the nation thing is part of her is a very successful part of her persona and actually you know you were the contrast of Johnson
一个给你端上燕麦粥的母亲，基本上就是这样。她没有给你什么真正可怕的东西，但也算不上什么特别美味的东西。不过，这种“国母”的形象是她非常成功的人格特质的一部分。事实上，你之前提到与约翰逊的对比……
different political personas work in different environments and when you've talked about this with Rome and somebody like Nero I mean I know it's a ridiculous comparison but difference well i mean i think a politician needs to adjust their presentation to the expectations of the society they're living in and they and what works in one will not you know theresa may is actually in some ways a very good comparison with angela merkel and she didn't work in Britain, she would have probably worked much better in Germany. Yeah, yeah. I mean, another kind of interesting contrast with Germany and both Britain and France
不同的政治人格在不同的环境中发挥作用。当你把这一点与罗马或像尼禄这样的人物进行对比时——我知道这可能是一个荒谬的类比——但区别在于……我的意思是，我认为政客需要根据他们所处社会的期望来调整自己的表达方式。在一个环境中奏效的东西，在另一个……特雷莎·梅在某些方面其实与安格拉·默克尔非常相似，但她在英国行不通，如果换在德国，她可能会做得好得多。是的，是的。我的意思是，与英国和法国相比，另一个有趣的对比是，
is that when there was that tsunami, and the reactor in japan got crippled that merkel's response was actually one of seems a panic closed down all nuclear reactors with the result that germany now its carbon footprint is twice that of france or yeah britain i think the colossal amounts of their energy they get from fossil fuels something like like a third or a quarter. Which is also going back to the Nord Stream. Right. Well, this could be her biggest legacy, I think, actually. So obviously we're recording this at a time when people are saying that there may be power cuts in Britain because of the lack of gas. And we've got queues of petrol stations and all kinds of things. So energy crisis seems very salient here.
当那场海啸发生、日本的核反应堆遭到严重破坏时，默克尔的反应似乎是惊慌失措，立刻关闭了所有的核反应堆，结果导致德国现在的碳足迹是法国或英国的两倍。我的意思是，他们能源中有相当大一部分来自化石燃料，大约三分之一或四分之一。这也是回到了“北溪”项目。对，好吧，这可能正是她最大的政治遗产，我认为确实如此。我们录制这期节目的时候，人们正说英国因为缺乏天然气而可能面临停电，加油站排起了长队，各种情况都有。所以能源危机在这里显得非常突出。
But actually, Germany's energy crisis is, in the long term, kind of much more crippling. Well, is it an energy crisis? I mean, they've got a deal with Russia. Well, it depends if you put the energy crisis in the context of global warming, of the kind of the macro level that actually to give him credit johnson at least is yeah affecting to to care about talk about with his muppets references um yes references to sophocles to be fair to him uh well i mean but so part of the the um one of the kind of consequences of Johnsonian flippancy is that you can just suddenly kind of change your mind.
但实际上，从长远来看，德国的能源危机更具毁灭性。嗯，这真的是一场能源危机吗？我的意思是，他们和俄罗斯有协议啊。嗯，这取决于你是否把能源危机放在全球变暖的宏观背景下来看——至少约翰逊在这一点上，借用布偶青蛙的梗……是的，借用索福克勒斯的梗，平心而论……
You know, I mean, he was he was massively anti-green and now suddenly he's going on about Kermit. Yeah, I think that's true. And I think there's all kinds of questions about that Nord Stream project. So for people who don't know, this is, as Tom said, this is this pipeline that goes basically from Russia to Germany. It bypasses Eastern Europe, the Baltic states. So what it does is it makes Germany dependent on Russian natural gas. But it means that, in a way, you can sell out those countries in between those two places. And actually, Germany, one of the stories that's never reported in Britain or America about Germany, one of the stories that's never reported in Britain or America about Germany.
所以，约翰逊式轻浮的后果之一，就是你可以突然改变主意。我的意思是，他曾经极力反对环保，而现在突然开始大谈特谈科米蛙。是的，我认为确实如此。关于“北溪”项目，存在着各种各样的问题。对于不了解的人来说，正如汤姆所说，这是一条基本上从俄罗斯通往德国的天然气管道。它绕过了东欧和波罗的海国家。所以它所做的事，是让德国对俄罗斯的天然气产生依赖。但这意味着，在某种程度上，你可以出卖这两个地区之间的那些国家。事实上，关于德国，有一件在英国或美国从未被报道过的事……
It's in the last 10 years, Germany has become one of Russia's key trading partners. There are all kinds of links. And China's, right? Yeah, and China's. We talk all kinds of things. We talk about Gerhard Schroeder. So lobbying links and all these kinds of things between Germany and Russia. Angela Merkel spoke to Vladimir Putin every week on the phone.
在过去的十年里，德国已经成为俄罗斯最关键的贸易伙伴之一。这里面存在着各种各样的联系。还有中国的联系，对吧？是的，还有中国的联系。我们谈到了各种各样的事情，比如格哈德·施罗德的游说联系，德国和俄罗斯之间所有这些形形色色的关系。安格拉·默克尔几乎每周都会和弗拉基米尔·普京通电话。
Even though she hated dogs. Well, he did this notoriously. It's weird that he would do that. She's one of his pals. He got this big black Labrador to sort of stalk around her. The photos are actually... Well, that's kind of...
尽管她讨厌狗。嗯，他确实做过那件出了名的事。真奇怪他会这么做。她是他的密友之一。他弄了一只巨大的黑色拉布拉多在周围晃悠。那些照片实际上……嗯，那真是……
Yeah, it's very Russian. But they would speak sometimes in russian they'd speak he speaks german she speaks russian um and she believed that she had a almost a unique insight among western leaders into russia's mindset but i mean against that so against the fact that she has cozied up to russian gas suppliers and uh so on and she's she's uh cut um victor orban a lot a lot of slack because even though they obviously have completely contradictory opinions say on refugees um a lot of german manufacturing is in hungary and so on so um she's very kind of practical um maybe cynical i might say on that school but I think she
是的，非常俄罗斯。但他们有时会用俄语交谈。他会说德语，她会说俄语。她相信自己在西方领导人中对俄罗斯的心态有着几乎独一无二的洞察力。不过，与此相对的是——尽管她与俄罗斯的天然气供应商走得很近，并且对维克托·欧尔班网开一面，因为尽管他们在难民等问题上显然有着完全对立的观点，但很多德国制造业都在匈牙利等等——所以她非常务实……或许在这一点上可以说她有点愤世嫉俗。但我认为她……
I mean the reason that Remainers in Britain love her is that she has she kind of has put the integrity of the European Union and Germany's dominant position within it kind of centre stage so to that extent
英国的留欧派之所以深爱她，原因在于她将欧盟的整体性以及德国在其中的主导地位放到了核心舞台上。所以在这种程度上，
she has kind of stuck up for Western values. Well I think she has a vision of the eu um that that absolutely does have germany center stage and i think germany is more now that britain has left the eu obviously germany is now 20 of the population more than 20 of the gdp um france is probably the only counterweight i mean effectively the the eu has become more and more german it's interesting with... Obviously, the Franco-German relationship throughout this period has been central right the way back to Adenauer.
她一直在捍卫西方价值观。嗯，我认为她对欧盟有一个愿景，那就是绝对以德国为中心舞台。而且我认为，在英国脱欧之后，德国现在占了欧盟人口的20%以上，GDP的20%以上。法国可能是唯一的制衡力量。实际上，欧盟已经变得越来越德国化了。有趣的是……显然，从阿登纳时代开始，法德关系在整个这一时期一直处于核心地位。
Yeah, far more than the German, Anglo-German. Oh, completely. But, you know, Colomitron standing together in cemeteries is kind of one of the defining images of the 80s, isn't it? Absolutely. But, I mean, again, Macron has been pushing Merkel kind of one of the defining images of the 80s isn't it absolutely but um i mean again macron has been pushing merkel to kind of beef up european defense i mean that's and that's the backdrop to the um the bust up with with the british and american australian submarine thing
是的，远超德英关系。哦，完全如此。但是，你知道的，科尔和密特朗并肩站在墓地里的画面，是80年代的标志性图像之一，不是吗？绝对是的。但是……马克龙一直在敦促默克尔……标志性图像之一，绝对是的。但是……马克龙一直在敦促默克尔加强欧洲防务，这就是英国、美国和澳大利亚潜艇事件爆发的背景。
um is that actually it's not only britain's let him down, it's also Germany. The French want a friend. They just want a friend. Well, I mean, Macron wants a Europe that, as every French president has done, wants a Europe that can, led by France, that is effectively independent of America. Yeah, I think that's absolutely right.
实际上，不仅是英国背叛了他们，德国也是如此。法国人只是想要一个朋友。他们只是想要一个朋友。好吧，我的意思是，马克龙想要一个由法国领导的、实际上独立于美国的欧洲，就像历任法国总统所做的那样。是的，我认为这绝对正确。
And he's been pushing and pushing Merkel to do that, and she hasn't wanted to do it. Well, I mean, that's because, partly because of this legacy that's hung right. And he's been pushing and pushing Merkel to do that, and she hasn't wanted to do it. Well, I mean, that's because, partly because of this legacy that's hung over the whole podcast, the World War legacy. I mean, this sort of, I know this seems like a parody of a sort of British history podcast
他一直在不断敦促默克尔这样做，但她一直不愿这么做。嗯，部分原因正是因为那种一直悬在整个播客上空的二战历史遗产。我的意思是，我知道这看起来像是英国历史播客谈论德国时的某种刻意模仿，比如巴尔特·福蒂（Basil Fawlty）式的“不要提战争”，但我认为你不可能不提它。我认为这是绝对的……你知道的，你现在访问柏林，它依然历历在目。这种历史赋予了德国人一种在欧洲首屈一指的意识——对军国主义危险的警惕，以及激昂的政治言辞所能造成的破坏。仅仅为了描述德国人在20世纪所遭受的苦难——左右翼的独裁统治，
talking about Germany, the kind of Basil Fulte don't mention the war, but I don't think you can not mention it. I think it's absolutely, you know, you visit Berlin now and it is still there. And the sort of, what it gave Germans was a consciousness unmatched in, I think, in Europe of the sort of dangers of militarism, the damage that impassioned political rhetoric can do. I mean, just to describe the horrors that Germans endured in the 20th century, the dictatorships of left and right,
你知道的，这与英国或法国（甚至包括经历过占领的法国）的任何经历都完全不在同一个宇宙里。我们还没有真正讨论的另一件事，也反映了我们绝对不是一个政治播客，那就是……
you know, it's a different universe from anything in Britain or indeed in France, actually, even with the occupation. The other thing that we haven't really talked about and it reflects the fact we're definitely not a politics podcast is of course that it's
我们绝对不是一个政治播客，这几乎总是依赖于联合政府。
almost always dependent on coalitions. the fact we're definitely not a politics podcast is is of course that it it's um uh almost always dependent on coalitions yes and we see that now that basically you know the cdu and spd both got the same basically the kind of same number of votes um and so there's going to be lots of horse trading and so probably merkel will remain chancellor for weeks maybe months so you don't get the bear pit adversarialism of British politics. That obviously also is a difference and is a structural one,
这一点我们现在也能看到，基本上……基民盟和社民党得到的选票基本上差不多，所以将会进行大量的政治交易，因此默克尔可能会继续担任几周甚至几个月的总理。所以你不会看到英国政治那种斗鸡般的对抗性。这显然也是一个区别，而且是一个结构性的区别，
again, designed to keep the spectre of dictatorship at bay. That's not in any way a profound observation. No, I think it's a good observation. I thought we should kind of just chuck that into the mix. Do you know what, Tom? Do you think we talk to Germany out out now the producer said to us before we started maybe 20 25 minutes and we've waited on for um an hour uh so i think we should definitely
同样是为了将独裁的幽灵拒之门外。这绝不是什么深刻的观察。不，我认为这是一个很好的观察。我觉得我们应该把这个也加进来。你知道吗，汤姆？你觉得我们对德国的探讨够了吗？制作人在我们开始之前说大概20到25分钟，而我们已经滔滔不绝地讲了一个小时了。所以我觉得我们绝对应该
um call a halt and i will go off to contemplate my signed photographs of helmut schmidt and you can go and do whatever German activity seems to you fitting I'm actually going to go and watch the Sopranos film which isn't German at all this is the exactly the sort of louche life that
到此为止了。我要去欣赏我收藏的赫尔穆特·施密特的签名照片了，而你可以去做任何你觉得合适的德国活动。我实际上打算去看那部《黑道家族》的电影，那一点也不德国，这完全是那种放浪形骸的生活。
the listeners will talking of films we are doing a very exciting event aren't we yes we are at the Odeon Leicester Square this is the first time we've spoken about it publicly on this podcast it's on the 14th of November
听众朋友们将谈论电影，我们要举办一个非常令人兴奋的活动，对吧？是的，我们在莱斯特广场 Odeon 电影院，这是我们第一次在这个播客中公开谈论这件事，时间是 11 月 14 日。
14th of November we're going to be doing history and the cinema in the cinema what could be more appropriate and I don't think the tickets have yet gone on sale maybe they have maybe they haven't um check our channels on twitter we will advertise the tickets there are lots of them we'd love to see as many listeners as possible uh we should be talking about some very entertaining films some controversial choices as
11 月 14 日，我们将把历史搬进电影院，还有什么比这更合适的呢？我想门票可能还没开始发售，也许售了，也许没售，嗯，请查看我们在推特上的频道，我们会在那里宣传门票，有很多票，我们希望尽可能多的听众能来，嗯，我们将讨论一些非常有趣的电影，还有一些颇具争议的选择，
well including one that i think i described as the worst portrayal of a bottom in cinema history well if that's not enough to get you visible i mean what else would you rather be doing on a sunday afternoon so on that note we will see you next time thank you for listening to the Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
包括一部被我形容为电影史上对底层最糟糕刻画的电影。如果这还不足以吸引你，那么你在周日下午还愿意做什么呢？就此而言，我们下次再见，感谢收听《历史的剩余》。如需收听加长节目、抢先体验、无广告收听以及参与我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。